We know inequality's can be solved just like equations. But there is one
exception. An inequality sign behaves different when you multiply or divide both
sides by a negative value. Let's look at that. I am going to start by not doing
division or multiplication, I am going to do subtraction. First, I subtract one
from both sides, and I get 1 is greater than 0. Then, I can subtract 2 from both
sides and I get negative 1 is greater than negative 2. This causes a lot of
trouble for students. Let's look at this. Here's negative 1 and here's negative
2. We know negative 1 is closer to 0, it's further to the right on the number
line, so it must be bigger in value compared to negative 2. But we're not after
comparing numbers here. We want to know about the inequality sign. I've
rewritten negative 1 is greater than negative 2 and instead of doing the
subtraction twice, what if we just would've multiplied? If we multiplied both
sides of our inequality by negative 1, we'll get negative 2 and negative 1. But
I can't just carry my inequalities straight down. We know negative 1 is greater
than negative 2, so the sign has to reverse in direction. The same is true when
dividing by a negative 1. We know when we divide by a negative 1, we change the
signs of the numbers. So, I'll still need to flip my inequality sign. These
inequalities might look different, but they're actually equivalent statements.
Here, I have negative 1 is greater than negative 2, and here, I have negative 2
is less than negative 1. If we flip this entire inequality, we can see that we
wind up with the same thing. We get negative 2 is less than negative 1. The key
thing to remember when solving inequality problems is to reverse the direction
of the sign when you multiply or divide both sides by a negative.